Just as materials can change width and
height, they can also change elevation.
We saw a glimpse of this with
the magnetic reaction of
buttons to the touch of your finger,
but this can also occur with
interactions such as scrolling.
Consider two surfaces which start off
in the same plane and move together and
lock step.
At a certain point,
one surface may need to stick and
raise up to allow
the other to pass below it.
We call this a seam to step transition.
The two adjacent surfaces
first form a seam.
But when the lower surface slides
below the other, they form a step.
>> For example, this app employs
an extended app bar that collapses to
a standard height and pins to the top
of the screen as the user scrolls.
So you see the elevation increasing.
Now, you can build this effect entirely
in XML using the new at bar layout and
collapsing toolbar layout.
Let's look at some layout XML code.
At the root,
we start with coordinator layout
which helps coordinate behaviors
across several kinds of views.
In this case it will coordinate
the scrolling of a list
with the scrolling of our app bar.
Since CoordinatorLayout is in
the android design support library.
We'll need to references it
by its full class name and
also include the app name space for
support library attributes.
We'll use and AppBarLayout
under the CoordinatorLayout and
give it the expanded
height we want of 168dp.
Within that we'll include
a CollapsingToolbarLayout and
tell it to scroll off the screen
until it reaches the collapsed size,
that's this exitUntilCollapsed flag.
Inside that we'll place
our Toolbar widget.
And give it the smaller height we
want to collapse to the 56dps.
Note that the collapsing toolbar
layout will be responsible for
drawing the title.
The toolbar widget here is only
responsible for drawing the icons.
Finally, the other widget
here will be a RecyclerView,
which uses a special
predefined layout behavior
that triggers appbar_scrolling
when the RecyclerView is scrolled.
The Android design support
library does all the rest.
Check out the documentation for scroll
flags in layout behaviors to find out
about other great scrolling behaviors
you can build with the library.
>> Using these techniques we can
divide our UIs into surfaces
to communicate the relationship and
provide interaction cues.
Interfaces should be dynamic.
Responding to user interaction and
clearly communicating
any changes in state.
Remember these techniques when trying
to express the relationship between
your UI elements.
They'll help make your screens
immediately comprehensible and
make your app much more intuitive.
Let's go to James, who will show you
how to put this to practise with code.